if you could say one thing to Chloe
right now what would you say I love you
and um thank you for being there for me
when I can't walk or talk you know when
you marry someone afternoon 30 days I
don't think that level will go away you
know I'm seeing a piece of paper she
says that we met together
that love will never go away have you
guys kind of made amends now as a come
full circle I mean I wouldn't call it
amends I've spoke to spoken so recently
if you call that amends
how was your relationship with the rest
of the Kardashian family especially Kris
how was it oh how is in there I'm you
know I really have much relation there
we don't really have much of a
leadership now do you think Kris had
your best interests at heart
I think she did yeah you know even in
Vegas no even in Vegas yeah yeah I think
she did
or was she protecting the brand I mean
while she's always gonna protect the
brand you know she's great at that she's
always gonna do that and I'm not mad at
her for doing that Lamar Odom getting
candid about the Kardashians what do you
think about her and Tristan
he's telling all in his new memoir
darkness to light tune into et on TV on
May 28th for more you held nothing back
did you
I try to keep a roof
[Music]